[Music]
asking everybody about one amazing woman
who's missing tonight demi lovato she's
nominated for several things but she's
not here
I just wondered if you had any thoughts
on you know how transparent she's been
with her fans on this whole journey and
what you think of it all I'm known to me
since I was a kid like really young and
I love her more than anything in the
world so I'm so much and like I love how
honest she's been with everybody and so
I love you to me I'm rooting for you and
I'm praying for you we're like childhood
family you know so have you talked to
her at all samberly I love yous and I
have spoken with her and honestly I just
kind of send so much love we all go
through our own struggles in life and I
feel like it's incredibly brave of her
to be so open about it and also like
think being famous is kind of hard to go
through things like that you know like
having everybody in your business is
kind of obviously invasive so I just
said your love and healing from whatever
place I can and she knows I love her
just give her her space and let her heal
I think is the most important thing I
have not had the opportunity to speak
with her just yet but you know I commend
her strength taking opportunity like
this where most people will be judging
you for her to be out there in the
public and embrace it and know that none
of us are perfect and we all need help
and you know especially we all have
certain burdens and she's dealing with
her than the public and I pray and wish
her nothing but good energy and recovery
hi honestly I I've always expected how
open she is about her struggles I think
she's incredible she's strong she's
mainly inspiring and I know she can
overcome it she's a strong person
we love you Demi you're so strong we
know you'll come back stronger than ever
and I can't wait for her return
[Music]